hagamos un poco de práctica
simplificando expresiones peliagudas que
tengan exponentes y justo aquí tenemos
una expresión peliaguda
que vamos a trabajar así que te invito a
que pausa el vídeo y veas si puedes
reescribir la en una manera más simple
ok ahora vamos a resolverlo juntos lo
primero que me llama la atención es el
numerador de aquí tenemos 125 elevado a
la potencia menos un octavo por la misma
base por el mismo número elevado a la
potencia cinco octavos tenemos 125
elevado a las cinco octavos por lo tanto
puedo reescribir este numerador déjame
ponerlo con este color puede reescribir
todo esto que tengo aquí de la siguiente
manera esto es exactamente lo mismo
usando lo que ya sabemos de las
propiedades de los exponentes que 125
125 elevado a la suma de los dos
exponentes a la menos un octavo a la
menos un octavo y a esto le vamos a
sumar cinco octavos cinco octavos
y bueno claro todo esto entre nuestro
denominador que es 5 elevado a la 1 mes
ahora bien estas dos expresiones son
equivalentes porque observa todo lo que
hice fue sumar estos dos exponentes
porque tienen la misma base y además
estoy multiplicando a estas dos
expresiones estoy multiplicando el 125
elevado a la potencia menos un octavo
por el 125 la misma base elevado a las 5
octavos y es por eso que estos dos
exponentes se suman y entonces cuánto es
menos un octavo más cinco octavos
bueno pues menos un octavo más cinco
octavos eso es lo mismo que bueno cuatro
octavos o un medio entonces todo esto se
simplifica a un medio y me queda 125 al
a un medio entre 5 elevado a la 1 medio
tienen la misma potencia por lo tanto
puedo escribir esto de la siguiente
manera esto va a ser exactamente lo
mismo que 125 125
a su vez entre 5 entre 5 y todo esto
elevado a la potencia un médium todo
esto elevado a la potencia un medio es
decir sí elevó 125 a la potencia un
medio y lo divido entre 5 elevado a la
misma potencia a la potencia en medio
eso es exactamente lo mismo que si
hiciéramos primero la división de 125
entre 5 y después lo que obtengamos
elevarlo a la potencia un medio
ahora bien cuánto es 125 entre 5 bueno
eso es muy fácil 125 entre 5
es lo mismo que 25 estos dos se pueden
reducir a simplemente 25 por lo tanto me
va a quedar 25 elevado a la potencia un
medio y cuánto es 25 elevado la potencia
en medio bueno pues eso es la raíz
cuadrada principal de 25 y eso ya
sabemos cuánto es esto es lo mismo
así que ya está simplificamos toda esa
expresión peliaguda y nuestro resultado
nos da 5 está de lujo esto se puede
simplificar muy bien ahora bajemos la
pantalla para hacer un nuevo ejercicio
vamos a hacer otro más y este es un poco
más interesante ya que aquí empezamos a
involucrar una variable la variable w
pero bueno realmente de alguna manera es
el mismo proceso que la anterior así que
lo primero que te debe de llamar la
atención es que tenemos de nuevo acá
abajo en el denominador la misma base
tenemos la misma base que es tres veces
w elevado al cuadrado y aquí también
tengo tres veces w
elevado al cuadrado por lo tanto que me
va a quedar bueno esto va a ser lo mismo
que y en la parte de arriba voy a seguir
teniendo lo mismo 12w elevado a la
séptima todo esto a su vez elevado a la
menos tres medios muy bien y esto a su
vez está dividido entre y recuerda
la misma base así que esto es lo mismo
que tres veces w elevado al cuadrado
esto a su vez elevado y recuerda como
tenemos la misma base elevado a una
potencia por la misma base elevado a
otra potencia las potencias se suman me
voy a tomar la suma de menos dos tercios
más menos cinco sextos dejan escribirlo
me voy a tomar la suma de este más éste
lo cual es menos dos tercios muy bien ya
esto le vamos a sumar cinco sextos de
lujo y cuánto es menos dos tercios menos
cinco sextos
pues bien menos dos tercios es lo mismo
que menos cuatro sextos déjame notar lo
que esto es lo mismo que menos cuatro
sextos ya esto le vamos a quitar cinco
sextos muy bien y cuántos esto esto va a
ser lo mismo que me
9 sextos y si sacamos tercera arriba y
abajo me queda lo mismo que menos 3
de lujo entonces menos dos tercios menos
cinco sextos esto lo voy a quitar y voy
a poner aquí solamente menos tres medios
así que déjame quitar todo esto y poner
menos tres medios ahora bien
fíjate que aquí tenemos algo muy
interesante ya te diste cuenta de nuevo
tenemos la misma potencia tanto arriba
como abajo tenemos la misma potencia y
por lo tanto podemos hacer algo muy
parecido a lo que hicimos en el problema
anterior esto se puede simplificar y
como simplificamos esto bueno pues esto
va a ser igual esto va a ser igual que
arriba me va a quedar 12 w a la séptima
potencia abajo me va a quedar 3 w al
cuadrado 3 w al cuadrado y todo esto
todo esto lo voy a elevar a la potencia
menos 3
ahora lo padre de todo esto es que se
puede simplificar 12w a la séptima entre
tres w al cuadrado dos entre tres eso es
lo mismo que cuatro de estos dos voy a
obtener cuatro y después tengo doble
igual a séptima entre w grado bueno lo
puedes ver así podemos dividir tanto
arriba como abajo entre el doble o el
cuadrado o puedes decir que esto es w a
la potencia
7 - 2 entonces w a la potencia 72 es lo
mismo que w a la quinta potencia w a la
quinta potencia y vamos bien de lujo
esto nos quedaría de la siguiente manera
esto es lo mismo que déjame ponerlo con
este color voy a abrir un paréntesis y
voy a poner menos tres medios menos tres
medios ya que adentro voy a poner cuatro
w a la quinta potencia wv a la quinta
potencia ahora esto ya está bastante
simplificado ya es muy simple e incluso
estamos en un punto que de alguna manera
dependerá de la opinión de cada persona
es difícil decidir cuál es la expresión
más simple ya lo mejor dependerá de para
qué vas a utilizar esta expresión pero
podrían argumentar que todavía esto se
puede simplificar un poco así que vamos
a hacerlo vamos a simplificar un poco
más esto porque esto va a ser lo mismo
que 4 que 4 elevado a la menos 3 medios
lo voy a poner así 4 elevado a la menos
3 medios a la menos 3 medios que
multiplican
wv elevado a la quinta potencia lo voy a
poner así w elevado a la quinta potencia
esto a su vez elevado a la potencia
menos tres medios y una vez más lo único
que estoy haciendo es usando las
propiedades de los exponentes ahora 4
elevado a la menos tres medios vamos a
pensar un poco en eso lo voy a poner
aquí 4 elevado a la menos tres medios
elevado a la menos tres medios esto es
exactamente lo mismo que bueno lo
primero que puedo ver es
puedo convertir esta potencia en
positiva si pongo 1 entre 4 elevado a la
potencia tres medios le estoy cambiando
el signo a la potencia y ahora pensemos
un poco 4 si le saco la raíz cuadrada
voy a obtener 2 y 2 y lo elevó al cubo
voy a obtener 8 así que 4 elevado a la 3
medios es lo mismo que 8 o esta
expresión de aquí es lo mismo que déjame
cambiar de color
un octavo así que todas estas
expresiones que tengo aquí es lo mismo
que un octavo ya se ve mucho mejor así
que me quedaría esto igual a un octavo y
después tengo w
a la quinta elevado a su vez a la menos
tres medios bueno ahí solamente podemos
multiplicar los exponentes
esto me quedaría w elevado a la potencia
5 x menos tres medios cinco por menos
tres medios es lo mismo que menos 15
y ya está al final no sé cuál sea para
ti la más simple si está que tengo aquí
o esta que tengo aquí pero lo que sí sé
es que las dos tanto ésta como ésta son
equivalentes y ambas son mucho más
simples que bueno esta expresión con la
que empezamos